[Musica]
il cambiamento passata ai giovani
lo sentiamo dire sempre ma allora perché
proprio noi giovani nella maggior parte
dei casi abbiamo paura di dire quello
che pensiamo il cambiamento non risiede
proprio nelle idee che supportano le
nostre azioni e le nostre azioni anche
in futuro
e a pensarci bene è una paura insensata
che tutti quanti proviamo ma senza un
reale motivo anzi tenere per sé un
opinione equivale a cercare di
compromettere il futuro perché se noi
giovani non ci creiamo un opinione ora e
non la condividiamo rischiamo di
incorrere in un futuro in cui questo
atteggiamento passivo sarà la normalità
e a quel punto non solo potremmo avere
paura ma la possibilità di esporre si
potrebbe non essere presa nemmeno in
considerazione
ed è proprio da questa paura che nasce
il mio desiderio di farmi sentire anche
la mia volontà di farmi sentire che per
fortuna ho in comune con dei miei
coetanei con i quali stiamo condividendo
un percorso
stiamo formando c all'interno di una
nuova generazione di ragazzi che hanno
voglia di fare di imparare ma
soprattutto di farsi sentire e avremmo
potuto farlo in tantissime modalità ma
abbiamo deciso di porre al centro
dell'attenzione la nostra quotidianità
abbiamo dunque optato per il social
network perché nel bene o nel male e noi
giovani non utilizziamo nulla più dei
social network specialmente di instagram
è proprio su instagram nasce edita una
realtà editoriale a tutti gli effetti ma
con la particolarità di essere
interamente gestita e realizzata da
ragazze e ragazzi di età compresa tra 16
e 19 anni e mediante la nostra pagina
social abbiamo la possibilità di creare
a diverse tipologie di contenuti per cui
articoli video e semplici schemi grafici
ma tutto per raggiungere l'obiettivo che
ci siamo prefissati raccontare
l'attualità dal nostro punto di vista
e per farlo proponiamo due diversi
approcci all'attualità
il primo è il semplice racconto di un
avvenimento o di una dinamica sociale
mediante l'utilizzo di un linguaggio
prossimo ai nostri per locutori e per
facilitarne la comprensione non ci
limitiamo al cuore dell'argomento ma
cerchiamo di raccontare anche tutto il
background necessario per comprendere
appieno l'argomento ma soprattutto per
comprenderlo con maggiore interesse
il secondo approccio a quello a mio
avviso più interessante è avere la
possibilità di esprimere il nostro punto
di vista sia come singole persone che
come gruppo di giovani su un'idea una
tematica un argomento che riteniamo
importante condividere e questo secondo
aspetto come ho detto è il più
interessante ma anche il più difficile
da realizzare infatti dopo aver maturato
un po di esperienza posso assicurarvi
che prima di esporsi la paura è tanta si
teme il giudizio degli altri anzitutto
poi si teme di dire qualcosa ed inesatto
o ancora peggio di esprimersi male ma la
volontà di far sapere al mondo che
esistiamo che abbiamo delle idee che
vogliamo farle conoscere a tutti sono il
motore che ci spinge ad andare oltre
questa paura
ma come ho detto la volontà di farmi
sentire di far sapere la mia opinione
non è un'idea solo mia ho scoperto che
ci sono tantissimi ragazzi che hanno
voglia di impegnarsi per comprendere e
analizzare quello che succede loro
intorno e nel nostro gruppo però non ci
limitiamo a fare lo facciamo in modo che
il tempo che noi investiamo per
informarsi a proposito di una tematica
che ci interessa possa tornare utile a
qualche altro ragazzo qualche altra
ragazza che non ha tempo modo o anche
semplicemente voglia di farlo tramite i
mezzi tradizionali
adesso però mi piacerebbe raccontarvi un
aneddoto che mi ha visto protagonista in
prima persona una la gara di formula è
una nuova disciplina sportiva nata
qualche anno fa un paio di settimane fa
ho visto una gara con un mio amico
di questa disciplina dico appunto non
sapevo nulla e subito dopo mi ha molto
incuriosito quindi appena sono tornato a
casa mi sono informato online e ho
scoperto specifiche tecniche
funzionamento completi competitività
insomma tutto quello che c'è da scoprire
su uno sport e un paio di giorni
basandomi il prima di tutto sulla mia
esperienza diretta come spettatori ma
anche sulle nozioni che ho potuto
apprendere online abbiamo scritto un
articolo el abbiamo pubblicato sulla
nostra pagina social perché in effetti a
cosa serve studiare un evento leggere i
giornali piuttosto che prendere parte ad
un evento se non per farsi un'opinione
riguardo e per poterla condividere con
tutti gli altri d'altronde come diceva
anche canta e un po parafrasandolo
l'uomo è in relazione con tutto ciò che
gli sta attorno e anche in questo caso è
importante e relazionarsi
va anche precisato che però non è sempre
tutto facile e immediato come è stato
nel caso della formula ma alcune volte
raccontare le cose dal proprio punto di
vista
esprimere un proprio punto di vista
raccontare qualsiasi cosa insomma in
generale esporsi comporta anche delle
criticità ed è qui che torna in gioco il
ruolo fondamentale che ricopre la
collaborazione perché è vero siamo
giovani possiamo commettere degli errori
alcune volte più semplici altre volte
invece un po più gravi ma la volontà di
esporsi non può mai essere considerata
un errore può essere nel ragionamento o
può essere anche nella costruzione della
propria opinione lo sto utilizzando
fonti non attendibili
oppure noi continuando più volte le
informazioni che vogliamo utilizzare da
mettere alla base della nostra opinione
o legno che può essere anche
nell'esposizione ma la volontà di
esporsi non può mai essere considerata
un errore
e il confronto come avrete ben capito
per noi è molto importante
e
nella maggior parte di casi essa avviene
in maniera spontanea naturale
all'interno della nostra redazione senza
che ciò venga percepito dall'esterno ma
in alcuni casi invece fondamentale
chiesto stesso venga perseguito dall
esterno e che il confronto diventi parte
dell'inter atteggiamento è strumento
dell'informazione perché in effetti
partecipando ad un dibattito si guadagna
tutti sia i due protagonisti che
discutono tra di loro sia chi ha la
possibilità di guardarlo da fuori e
perché ha la possibilità di ascoltare
due tesi opposte
si scontrano tra di loro e quindi alla
possibilità di sentire se il dibattito e
ben influenza è ben organizzato entrambe
le opinioni senza essere eccessivamente
influenzato né dall'una né dall'altra
ipotesi e voi direte va beh non è che
stai dicendo una grande novità ed è vero
perché basta sapere che la l'importanza
riconosciuta alla pratica il dibattito è
antichissima basti pensare che anche gli
antichi 10 ripartiva dibattevano
permette anche molto prima dei dieci
dibattevano ma il concetto innovativo
che vogliamo portare noi alla perdita
del dibattito è che a discutere non
siano per forza due massimi esperti
dello sport e della politica per fare
degli esempi ma che possano essere anche
dei ragazzi che hanno voglia di
informarsi e di far sapere ai loro
coetanei che hanno un'opinione a
riguardo
anche qui mi piacerebbe raccontarvi un
esempio che ci ha visti protagonisti in
prima persona il voto elettorale ai
sedicenni se ne è tornato a parlare
recentemente e dall'opinione pubblica
sono state ascoltate diverse opinioni o
tutte molto rispettabili ma quasi mai
sono state ascoltate quelle dei 16 17
anni
insomma è una scelta bizzarra dato che
sarebbero proprio loro i principali
protagonisti di questo cambiamento
invece all'interno della nostra
redazione abbiamo avuto la possibilità
di discuterne abbiamo raccolto le
opinioni di 16 17 anni ognuno chi era
favorevole ha detto perché chi era
contrario ha detto perché sma
ma non è questo il punto importante ciò
che mi piacerebbe sottolineare è che
sono convinto che qualche 16
diciassettenne non avesse compreso di
essere egli stesso una persona cui
questa decisione avrebbe dovuto
interessare in quanto coinvolto
direttamente è vero magari mi aveva
sentito parlare a casa magari non aveva
sentito parlare in tv da qualche esperto
ma grazie a quel video dibattito
organizzato anche certamente è
strutturato con uno scopo didattico ap
si è iniziato a sentirsi parte della
discussione e magari perché no magari
successivamente ha pensato di poter e
dover approfondire per conto proprio
l'argomento in modo da sentirsi
interamente all'interno della
discussione è l'aspetto che mi piace di
più sottolineare è che tutto ciò sia
stato possibile grazie ad i suoi
coetanei che hanno avuto voglia di
impegnarsi di analizzare la situazione e
di parlarmi in prima persona
certo magari voi ritenete questo è un po
un discorso topico tutti che si
rispettano nella discussione si
aspettano vicendevolmente e forse un po
utopico lo è non lo nego ma io ci credo
e ci credo fermamente e dal momento che
il futuro siamo noi giovani voglio
mettermi in gioco e voglio provarci io
per primo e voglio dire a tutti quanti
voi che siete qua o magari state
guardando da casa e sperando che magari
anche grazie a questo discorso in futuro
possa cambiare la concezione che noi
giovani abbiamo del nostro ruolo
all'interno della società
ecco a tutti voi dico comunicate date e
portatori di conoscenza ma soprattutto
di interesse perché il futuro siamo e
saremo sempre noi giovani e dal momento
che lo siamo
cambiamo
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]